(audience clapping)
- Hi.
- You have a talk show.
- I know,
(laughs)
How did you end up becoming one of like
the great entrepreneurs of life
and I ended up on a talk show?
Like it's been almost 22 years.
I think it has been 22 years
since Never Been Kissed.
- Yeah, isn't that a trip?
I had my 17th birthday on the set.
- Aaw!
I mean we...
- I've Never Been Kissed.
- Just had the best time making that film.
- Yeah and everyone,
I mean you popped so many actors as well.
I mean It felt like camp,
but you also,
I mean you really took so many people
under your wing
and,
guided them
and a lot of us were
just really starting out
and you set the stage,
I would say for us
and gave us a platform to be successful.
So, thank you.
(audience claps)
- I mean, if I had anything to do with
some of your origin story
which I'm so proud to.
Holy cow! did you,
just come out of the gate swinging?
I mean,
it's just astonishing to me
that you were the one and so amazing.
Your light bulb went off
and you became an
extraordinary business woman,
but at the same time provided
a whole different avenue for moms.
- Yeah you know,
I guess it just came out of,
I went lobbied on Capitol
Hill for chemical reform
because I looked at this data around
the rise in illnesses,
basically coinciding
with the rise of the
industrialization of chemicals
that have been brought
into the marketplace
and put into
every single,
category
from detergents to baby products,
to makeup.
And it's making people sick
at like astronomical numbers.
And then when you look at
the Black and Brown communities
and I'm obviously part of that community.
I really felt like it was
a social justice issue.
And so I wanted to solve this
social justice issue
and also create a for-profit business
to sustain that initiative.
And then being able to give back
to families who were born
in unfortunate circumstances
and that's where a percentage of sales,
products,
and time
we donate since day one
at The Honest Company.
Our biggest partner has been BABY2BABY.
- And if you go to our website,
you'll be able to access all information
as well as a way to get
involved with BABY2BABY,
which is a company I've
been involved with now
for eight or nine years.
- You've been part of it up close
and your involvement in it
has actually allowed us
from being,
a nonprofit
that really was just
affecting one community
in Los Angeles and being
able to expand nationally.
Especially now that a
lot of kids due to Covid,
aren't able to go to,
you know pre-school
or to school.
They're not able to get
a lot of those essentials
but we have been able to
navigate through a lot
of those challenges,
and even at Honest,
we were able to develop
a solution with disinfecting sprays.
A disinfecting spray,
a wipe that's made from over 65% alcohol,
our hand sanitizer spray,
and masks for children and for adults.
And so we're also donating
to families in need with
the masks and sanitizers and stuff.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, straight talk.
How are you doing it?
You know we as women like
don't wanna ever not say
you can't have it all
you can't do it all.
But I just spent my weekend you know
I'm in like a whole self-improvement surge
for like how I talk to
myself in my own head.
And in my inner dialogue
was not very nice this weekend.
It was you know
(laughs)
How is a mom with your kids and your job
and everything.
How's your inner voice?
How is it?
(chuckles)
- Real talk.
I told everyone in the family
that I need a break from them.
(laughs)
So Kelly and I are actually gonna go away
for a week.
And I don't really know
what we're getting ourselves into.
I just know
that I can't be around my family anymore.
Cause I literally (chuckles)
I've had it.
I've had enough.
I just like, it's like,
and they all come down on me.
I'm like (chuckles)
you guys every time they ask me like,
"Mom, can I download this app?"
Or "Mom, can I get on the FaceTime mom?"
"Mom can I..."
and "Mom I'm hungry"
and "Is this outfit okay?"
"Can you help me?"
I'm like you're on a Zoom call.
Like don't talk to me.
I'm like talk to your dad
and then I just start nagging.
And then I'm just nagging
and I'm that person.
And they're like,
"Mom, your tone, you're so mean,"
you know and Cash is like,
"Gosh! I guess, you know
I guess I'm just gonna
go back into my man room'
and I'm like,
what else is new.
(laughs loudly)
Disappearing, for me to
deal with every thing.
So, yes, it's been fun,
it's been really fun.
(laughs loudly)
Now imagine,
I mean you have my nine year old
she doesn't wanna go to bed,
it's a fight every night.
- It is, I'm in hell right now
- Oh my.
- Because I slept.
- I'm like, are we renew it,
like what?
You know, you need to go to bed kid.
This isn't a thing.
We shouldn't talk about this.
And so I just said and she goes,
"Well you make dinner so late
every time you make dinner."
And am just like,
(laughs loudly)
here's the thing,
here's the thing
I'm gonna make dinner late.
You're gonna eat late
and then you're gonna get your butt to bed
right after that
and that's just the way it's gonna be.
That's just the way it's gonna be.
I don't know what to say
I'm not perfect
you're gonna eat dinner late.
(audience claps)
- Oh my God!
I already have loved you for 22 years.
And I just fall more and more in love
for so many reasons
but I just thank you
because I feel so much less alone.
(laughs)
(bright upbeat music)